Welcome to "Nos Cambiaron
Los Muñequitos. Thanks for joining us
in this new episode. Today we will speak
with David Pakman. For the last 15
years, David has run his own
political analysis program
The David Pakman Show
This program has around
one million subcribers on the Youtube
platform. David was born in
Argentina and moved to the US
at age 5, and has created a great
career with his program, and it is
truly a great, interesting
conversation. Today for the first time we will
enter the political world
We hope you will enjoy this
conversation with David Pakman. Let's begin
[Music]
Greetings, welcome to "Nos Cambiaron
Los Muñequitos." Today we are going to have
a conversation that will be super
interesting and for me, very challenging
because I'm going to speak with someone who,
although young, has incredible
experience
To give you context, he
has had a YouTube channel
for 15 years and he is already an expert,
while I feel like a novice.
Getting started, today we're
going to speak with David Pakman
David, how are you? Good, thanks
Thank you, I'm honored
to have you with me. I became aware of David
through his YouTube channel,
the famous recommendations by
the YouTube algorithm
for videos to watch, and I was surprised
by your depth,
professionalism, and surprisingly,
I read or saw that he was
born in Argentina, and he doesn't look it,
so I decided to ask him a question, whether he
speaks Spanish, and from that initial question,
we decided to do this recording, and I'm
very grateful to have the
opportunity to speak with David Pakman
David, you were born in Argentina. Talk to us
about your origins, your family are
immigrants who came from Europe,
tell us about your origins please
Sure, well I was born in Buenos Aires and
my parents as well, and of my four
grandparents, three were also born in
Argentina. One grandfather, my maternal grandfather
was from Poland, and in the 20's
I believe, I think '29, '31, more or less
his family left Poland for Buenos
Aires, as did many Jewish families
in Europe during that part of the 20th century, and
that's where my family got established and
that's where we live. When I was 5 in 1989, we
came to the United States, the economic
situation in Argentina was complicated
to put it one way, and Argentina in recent
decades many times has been
an example of bad economic situations,
of hyperinflation, from different political decisions
and of course when I was born
in '84 it wasn't long after the military
dictatorship, and so, well,
there were many complicated periods
but that's how in '89 we ended up
in Massachusetts in the United States, and there
more or less my life started over
Okay, and the move took place because
your parents were looking for better professional
or work options, or what
did your parents do?
Yes, it was -- yes, they looked for better
professional options but in a sort of
emergency situation or almost
emergency. In other words, the economic situation
in Argentina at that time was
very very
bad, so by chance, by luck, my
Dad knew another psychiatrist who --
my dad is a psychiatrist -- another Argentinean
psychiatrist who worked in Massachusetts
and he said to him, look, you can come
work, but you wouldn't be a doctor in
the US immediately, because you have to redo
a number of things
and at that time, the situation was
so complicated in Buenos
Aires that we left
in '89. Okay.
You arrive in the US at the age of 5, which
I imagine, that adaptation part,
adapting to this new culture, this
new language must not have been that
difficult because you were still in a development
phase, of growth
Yes, certainly, and there are anecdotes from my parents
of, for example, a few months after
arriving where I was refusing to
speak English, but my parents
could tell I could understand it
and they asked me, "so why --
what's going on, why won't you speak
at school, why don't you," and I said "no
it's that I'm waiting to go back to Buenos
Aires, it's not necessary to speak, and my
dad told me, "look, we aren't going to return,
this is the situation, we aren't going to return" and
from that moment on, okay
I started to speak (English) and the situation started to
normalize, but yes, it's a difficult
situation, now I realize,
especially now as an adult,
that's it's much easier at age 5 than at
15 in many senses,
from the standpoint of language, from
the standpoint of understanding and
integrating oneself into the culture, but, but yes,
it had its complexities
And I'm surprsied that at the beginning you
didn't want to speak, and you've made an
entire career from communicating and from disseminating and
from speaking, truly incredible
I hadn't thought of in those terms, but
that's interesting, right because I could work in
field where speaking
is not that important, speaking with other
people maybe would be less important
but no, that's an interesting observation
David, what did you study?
I studied, at UMass, the University of
Massachusetts, I studied economics and
communication, and following that I entered
directly into business school, at
Bentley, at that time it was Bentley
College, now it's Bentley University, in the Boston
area, and there I studied business. Que bien, que bien
Did you have, when you chose that field
did you have in mind something planned
in terms of what you wanted to do with your life?
en que querías hacer con tu vida
Did you choose that thinking of something specific or what is a,
sometimes decisions that we make as
adolescents, based on how you
saw yourself in that moment?
Well, I could tell with each year
in school that I had less interest i
working in traditional fields like,
for example in business school, the
majority of my classmates went to
work at banks or in finance, that
type of thing, and I realized through a couple
of internships that it didn't
interest me, and luckily by then
I had started my program
during the, when I was in my third
year at UMass I started the show in a
very casual way
and I had the idea of upon finishing
my MBA, trying one
year
doing the show in a more professional
way, more like a real job
Right. And I decided to do --
I'm wondering,
you said in a "casual" way, we are
talking 15 years ago, now that
everyone knows YouTube,
everyone wants to do something on
YouTube, or wants to make content, but 15
years ago, that
"casual manner," wasn't so casual
right? Somethign was just
starting, which didn't have so much
obvious potential, right? For
one person who was maybe visionary
saw it, how common that it happens
to start to your program
It started in a very
slow way, in practice, in other words, the
program 15 years ago didn't have anything to do with
the program that one sees today
15 years ago, it was a show in the basement
of a community radio station in Northampton,
Massachusetts, it was only audio, it was
once every two weeks, so
imagine, now it's a dialy program,
5 days per week, with video
At that time, it was only audio, once
every 14 days, and over time, as
it interestd me more, it grew to once
per week, we added a visual
component in 2009, in 2008 in fact
was when I had the idea of
adding a visual component, and that
period of exploring that lasted seven, eight
months. After seven, eight months,
finally we obtained the camaras, the
visual elements, and the next
era of the program started, and right, from
that moment, Youtube in 2009
was something different, and of course now with
mobile phones and half the
audience consuming the content in
video format on a mobile phone, now it's another
world completely. And so
in the case, for example, for you to
see the reach of YouTube, of that platform, which
I believe is the second largest
search tool apart
from Google. For example, last night
I was trying to fix a ceiling fan
and the first thing I do is
search YouTube, and it's become
so integrated into our lives that
for example I learned to do a
podcast through videos on youtube and
it has become something that's a natural
part of our daily lives each day
and I'm wondering, initially
when you started in the basement of the community
station, the topics were
similar to now, you were talking about
political analysis, you were talking about
economic analysis, what were you talking about in
those early days?
It was very similar to today's program
of course I had less experience, I
It was
a totally different political moment, in other words
at that time the President was
George W Bush, and I was much younger
of course, at that time, so my
perspective has changed over time, and
no, but in a general sense, it was
very similar program at that time
Right. It sounds like
George W. Bush
something that I've talked about, that I've thought about
I haven't said it, suddenly with the
president we have, suddenly we sometimes
look back, at Bush, we look at him with
certain yearning, like "wow"
compared to the president we have, George W.
Bush, with all his limitations, was
right?
He had much more capacity, let's
say it like that, than the President that
we have now
Right, that was another thing altogether, and that's
a conversation I want to be careful
with because there are times that on the show
I'll say things like, for example when
we think of the year 2012, and the possibility
that Mitt Romney would replace Obama,
now thinking about that seems so
inoffensive in a sense,
Romney compared with what we have now, that
doesn't mean it was a good idea,
so I always want to clarify that I
didn't vote for him, but there was
a difference in that in 2012, I felt
that, for example, the four years that
would follow, economically would be more or
less stable, independent of whether
it were Romney or Obama. At this
point, for me, things feel very
different, very very different, a much more
dangerous situation. Yes, we're not going to go
down that road because it's an extensive
conversation, but I wanted to
talk a little about how,
that program, which started,
as you mentioned, in a community TV station
a community station,
has evolved to the point that
you now have
on YouTube, you are close to 970,000
subscribers, is that right?
And I think you have -- It is, it is, and I say
close to 1 million because it's a more interesting
number for me, but yes, when
we started, I looked, it took us years
to get to 100,000, and from that
point there was an acceleration, and with
time, well, from 900,000 to 1 million
it will only have taken, if all
goes well, in a month or 6 weeks more
or less when we get to 1 million, it will
have been only a few months from
having reached 900
and that also has a lot to do with
the political environment, of course, the nevel
of interest that there is, but also that
so many people, as you were saying earlier,
use YouTube
as an everyday thing.
Right. My experience, for example,
sometimes I want to see teh content, and
I don't want to see so much analysis, right? And
sometimes it happens that I put on a station
for example, CNN, and I want to see
news, or I want to see what happened,
and in order to accumulate, to be able to generate
content for 24 hours of news, there
is a bit of news and lots of analysis,
and I don't want to see, right, so much
analysis, right, and so I think that
in that sense, for example
YouTube has allowed you one
to be selective, I want to see this specifically,
and I want to go directly to the meat
of the issue, so to speak, and I don't want
to be searching, prowling
listening to the opinion of many people
because, and I don't know, YouTube allows you
to do that, to directly select
what you want to see in a direct
way, and that convenience.
I wanted to ask you about this, you're close to
achieving 15 years of your project
right? And, how did you
over these 15 years, you've
grown professionally, but also you've
grown personally. They say men
don't mature as far as
the women, right, but you've had
a maturation process, of growing
of getting to know the world, how do you see yourself
compared to you 15 years ago, or
5 years ago, in terms of your
maturity, being able to manage so many
things that come alongside your
project, your channel, your program
proyecto a tu canal a tu programa
Well, from the standpoint of political views
which is what is most visible if someone
follows the program, what everyone sees
every day is the political perspective,
so let's talk about that first a bit.
There is a part of my audience which thinks
that over time, I've moved to the
right politically. It's not true, and
in fact, every couple of years, I use
there are different tests that you can do
on the internet, for example,
Political Compass is one, and every couple of years when
people start to tell me, no, no, now
you're sort of fascist, your
sort of right wing, each time I do one of those
tests and each time I'm more to
the left, is the truth, so that
from the standpoint of politics, but
from a more personal point of view,
look, 15 years is a lot, when I started
the program, I hadn't finished
university,
nor did I live alone, at that time I lived
with my mom, at that time, so in my life
a lot of things happened in the last
15 years, and in ways that maybe
are more subtle, it's noticeable in everything, everything
How I manage the business, how I think about
the importance of
vacation and having periods of not
working, for example, which 10 years ago
would have been a very different perspective
From the standpoint of
friends and family, in other words, everything has
changed in a sense, and at the same time,
the show continues to be the same one in a sense
Yes. If I ask you about maturity, it's
because I've seen, for example there's
a character, there's someone, not sure how to say it,
a political analyst, it's this Jesse
Lee Peterson, and you've been, on three
occasions on his program, which is, you guys
your way of thinking, for people who don't know
him, are completely different,
as much in
terms of philosophy, in your thoughts, in
the things you believe, but also in the sense
in which you address your arguments, the
way in which you speak, and so I was
able to see those three
appearances, in one of those appearances
he kicked you off the program, and despite
that, when watching the third apearance, I saw the way
in which you
are speaking with someone who
many people would see as enemies, or wants to
see you as enemies, and speaking in a way
let's say, I'm not sure if to say
"civilized," but in a way that's with
maturity, and that maturity is what I refer
to about how you can approach
speaking with people who can, who I
hear, and I can think
what are my irrational fanatical
reasons for why I can't
attribute logical thinking to them, and despite
this, you have the capacity with those
people to sit and talk about
certain topics, and that maturity is what
surprises me, that you can talk about that
Well look, that example,
truthfully, has nothing to do with
maturity. It has to do with the idea
that
when he kicked me off, it was a remote
video interview,
and when we got along well, I was
in Los Angeles in his studio, and it was
a completely different situation, and it's
a bit about deciding which of the characters
each person is going to play and thinking
that in each interview, but actually, many
people frequently ask, how
can it be that when you talk to for
example
a white nationalist, [Richard]
Spencer, how is it that you speak in such a normal
manner, as if he were a normal person,
and I always say the same thing, and that's that
started to scream, starting to yell,
interrupting the conversation doesn't benefit
me and it's not good for the audience
in practice, and it's always possible to value
speaking with someone whos ideas are so
differente, so opposed, but no that's
a decision more than anything
else, of okay, look, if we're going to do this,
let's make it worthwhile, let's have
the conversation. Right, yes, in that sense, I
tell you, I have to recognize that in reality,
it's incredible, because If I, for example,
had the opportunity to
speak, maybe,
maybe what I say might be controlled.
but my facial expressions, my gestures,
my face, that sarcastic face, it's something
one uses the body sometimes, one can't
dissimulate what the body is saying,
and for me those difficult conversations,
I'm going to listen to people,
and that's why in the case of Jesse Lee Peterson,
when everything he sees through the lens of, if you are
weak, or you are
strong, or you are macho, alpha, but no, you are
a macho beta, and it's like an
incredible mentality that I, I couldn't
maybe try to reason with a
person, obviously, but it's
what I really appreciate and in
particular I call maturity because,
I appreciate that you have the opportunity
to talk to these people, and truly
that the ideas flow, without, without th
personal part. Now that
interview in particular that you mentioned,
in Los Angeles with Jesse Lee Peterson,
sort of as a joke at the end of
the interview, I said that I think this
interiew will be of much interest
to the sociologists of the future, to the
psychologists, and I heard it
sort of as an insult, but at
the same time, it was true in a sense
Right, right, that's incredible. As
part of your job,
you've been exposed to
the criticisms of many people. I've seen
for example, people, other people
who have shows similar to yours
who accuse you of having bots
looking to raise your subscription numbers, and in
this field, to see who can gain more
subscribers, there are people who have
accused you of other things, right? Of the things
I've heard, they've accused you, from
accusing you of being atheist, right, as if it were
an insult, to being a neo-Nazi, and many
things, and so how do you manage this,
these attacks, which to begin with aren't
well-intenioned, they're meant to
interfere. How do you manage that?
Well, some are jokes, like for
examples, the one about getting to one million
YouTube subscribers is a joke with
a friend, so that one is sort of
a different thing, but look, the
truth is that if thereare serious threats, I
don't publicize them, I send them to
the authorities, and that's happened,
that's happened, so those
don't count in this because theyre another thing, another category,
let's say, they don't fall under
"the insults." So look, at the start,
15 years ago, 12 years ago when
everything started, I had a sort of fear of
saying what i thought, truthfully, because
of this idea that someone might not like
it, and what happens if they send me
a message, a negative message, an aggressive message
Eventually you get used to it and at this
point, each day we get some 3000, 4000
comments per day on our
different platforms and I don't get to read
them all, but when I see one and it's
negative, I try to say, okay well
there's also someone who said something
positive. The problem is that, I think there is
a tendency to pay more attention
to the negative things people say. Right,
so there can be 10 positive
comments and one negative, and it's very easy
to keep thinking about the negative. So
that's a general thing, I think, but
from the standpoint of the show, over
time,
as a result of there being more and more comments
every day, the truth is that I see
fewer and fewer as a percentage of what
comes in. Obviously you have, I imagine
a team of people who
help to manage these comments,
of response on the social
networks. Is it a large
team, as small team? It's a
team of four in total,
myself included, and in general my idea
is that the show is where I
talk to people about politics, and in
principle, when people send emails
we have on our website something
that says, if you send a political
comment, someone will read it, it might
be me, it might not, and if it's an
idea for something on the show, it will get
to the right place, but it's impossible
for me to talk about politics by email
with the audience
The same via twitter, so in
principle, the idea is that the team
pays attention to what's coming in and
when there are interesting ideas, we talk
about them on the show, but basically the
political discussion has to be
limited to the show because if not
it's impossible. Right, right. David, you
mentioned, as we mentioned a
moment ago, it was the comments from people
which, sometimes, it's true, they aren't
positive. I want to hear your opinion
about this. I get the impression that
suddenly, so much access to
information, to a forum, the social networks,
Twitter, suddently people, and I,
I believe,
and obviously my perspective is very
different to yours, you are -- I appreciate
very much your way of thinking, but I think
people, sort of suddently
believe their opinion, their opinion above
something, it's something almost sacred, to the point
that suddently, facts, what are
statistics, don't matter,
right?
For an example that
doesn't have to do with politics, but for
example, to think that in the year 2020,
there are people, there are movements that
believe the world, that
planet earth is flat, is incredible
But so it's like what's important
is, my opinion is as if sacred, and I have to
express my opinion even if I forget,
even if I don't pay attention to the facts.
What do you think about this phonemon?
Well there are two parts. First is the
idea of sacred opinions, there's a
term in English which is "sacred cow,"
which is a frequently used
idea, and my point of view is that
if one isn't being offensive merely
to be offensive, you know on purpose, to
generate a negative environment, it shouldn't
exist, this idea of ideas that can't
be questioned, ideas that are sacred
Good, it's better in general that that
no exist, but at the same time, we have to
be able to establish some facts to
be able to have these conversations in a
logical manner, so the problem that
frequently surfaces is that many
people say, there shouldn't be sacred
ideas,
but we can't come to an agreement
from the standpoint of the basic
facts. When we can't do that,
it's impossible to have a conversation about
opinions, and it's effectively as you
mention, the problem of flat
earth, flath earth is a serious
problem, but there are many others, and
especially now with what's
happening with the virus, it's very important an
and it's having real repercussions
In other words it's, how many people die, it's
a very very serious thing,
and without being able to establish basic facts, it's
very difficult to create a foundation for honest
discussion. Right, right.
Do you think -- there are people,
some can say, that Trump is
a good -- well, in Puerto Rico we say, in truth,
about our leaders, we've had
our political complications
in recent years, in our crisis,
also economically, but we say that
the village has the leaders it
deserves, or that it chooses, and
so that in the leaders that
surge, they are a reflection of
our village. In the case of Trump,
one can think that it's an anomaly, or
a manifestation, each time more clear,
of what the nited States is, or, or
of the relevance that a certain
part of the country of the United States
No, about that. How do you see it? It's a
very complicated topic, so knowing
where it makes the most sense
to start, I'm thinking a bit
It's true
that
for example, thinking about the November
election, I've said many times
that if after everything that's happened,
after how Trump won in 2016,
and everything that's happened since that
moment, 15,000 lies, false promises,
impossible promises, promises of things
that were never going to happen,
and ultimately the last 6 months, the
management of the virus, if after
all this, [Trump] wins again, in a sense
the country deserves it, and I'm in
agreement with that idea, but it's a bit
complicated because the US is a very very
large country, one of the largest countries
in the world, from the standpoint of
population, and there are parts of the country
that would be large countries alone, compared to
Europe, compared to other, to other
parts of the world,
that are in complete disagreement with everything
that's being done, everything that's
happening, and there are mechanism, including what
in English we
call "gerrymandeing" and also of course
this issue of manipulation of the
election by other countries or domestically with
the postal service or in different
ways
that there's also a question of, okay
but if he wins officially,
did he really win? Did he win by manipulating
some system? This is a serious question.
At the same time, so to sort of
sum up a bit, I agree that in
the end, if he wins again, we
deserve four more years and some
of us are going to have to decide, well
what do we do? Do we leave if it's possible or
no, not everyone can leave, what is each of us
going to do, but at the same time, I don't have
much confidence that what is announced on
the 3rd or 4th of November is going to be
the true result. Right, right, no
they've even asked Trump if
he would accept the results if he
loses and he's never said "yes," he
always says, we'll see when it
happens, right, so it's a
dangerous position because suddenly,
sometimes one says well look, there are
people and there are institutions,
organizations, and the institution are
there to ensure that the individual
can't fail, right, any error
by one person, the democratic
institutions are going to cover it. In
the case of President Trump,
like in the case of the Postal Service in which
there were a ton of manipulations and
things that are concerning, it's
true, and so I wanted,
it was a moment, the question
that I think I wanted to ask you, because
sometime's it's like, sort of
the syndrome, let's say also, or the
example I had in mind, the
syndrome of the beaten woman,
abused woman by her partner,
suddenly will even defend the partner, and
so I worry, or how do you see it that
suddenly -- before I remember, in the case of
Obama, for example, if one day he dressed
with a light-colored suit, that was
a scandal,
but suddently, with President
Trump, there are so many things that worry me
that are suddenly common, for example with
this dimension of the abused woman, where
suddenly we become
desensitized to all the things that
he does, and suddenly we're used to them,
we accept them,
when I believe that it's very
important that we don't let our guard down, nor
get used to
the things he does constantly,
the constant lies
Of course
how we evaluate the job of a
President has completely changed in
the lat four years, and each
week, or much more than once a
week, there's some scandal, and a term
in English which I call
"hyper-normalization," which would be hyper
normalization, is a process in which --
this happens to all of us, this happens to be because
I follow this every day, so I,
I'm used to every
day, there's a scandal
and the people that follow it in a more casual
way, like the people who have
jobs that don't relate to
politics but they follow politics a bit
also start to become used to it and it's
very, very difficult to prevent that, but it's
very important, because you can almost pick a month
in this presidency, that month contains more
scadals than what Obama had in eight
years, but at the same time, it's like
humans get used to things very
easily, to the current situation, and that's
a serious problem from the standpoint of
the election. Right, right, no and
for example, there are things that I --
again, from my perspective of the United States,
highlighted from Puerto Rico, is another
story
-- a colony for more than 500 years, and all that --
my perspective is different, but let's see, for
example, in the
things that previously were not capital
sins
for example, I forget the name
of the concept now where you place your
family uin political positions, or you
employ them, it's the same --
Nepotism -- You see the -- Nepotism, so
notable, in the case of Trump therefore --
before that was something that was very
serious now, suddenly it's so normal,
having your entire family, and seeing in the
convention, to see
his future daughter-in-law, his son't girlfriend,
speaking, and suddenly seeing that they are
using the White House to make
speeches, to have naturalization
ceremonies as part of the
convention, and there are so many things
that previously were mortal sins
and now are sort of normal, and over time
it's like each time he expands more the
borders, things keep expanding
what they do. One incredible thing
well, imagine, many times speaking
with friends, I tell them, imagine if
Clinton were president, and her daughter at
a convention, or G20 summit, G8
for example, were seated at the table
in place of the Secretary of State,
for example,
it would be 24 hours per day for weeks on
Fox News, talking about nepotism, saying
she can't legally be in
that position, it's the worst of the worst
that has happened in the history of the United States,
it would be incredible, and it happens every week,
every month, and now the Trump's
son-in-law, these days on the first flight
from Tel Aviv
to UAE, and there as a functionary
of the government despite no being voted in, not
confirmed by the Senate, he's in a
position because Trump decided
he wanted him there
It's that the entire conversation
has changed in the last four years
and it has slid towards the more and more
absurd over time, but right, in my
case, since I can understand, let's say
it in thise way, I can understand
that someone has decided to vote for
the President because he is a Republicans and
has all their beliefs, and truthfully it's
let's say his ideology and
they decide to vote that way, but
I'll give you for example a case of some
friends of mine who are defenders
of President Trump, they are Christian
people, they are religious
and what surprises me is that for
example, you want your children
to be honorable, to be honest, not to
lie, not to mistreat, and
those things you ingrain in your children
if you want that, or for example if you
go to
a car dealer to buy a
vehicle, and if the salesperson seems
very strange, you don't trust in him and you
leave, and so all of those things that
we don't want in our lives, in humans
who are alongside us, which we don't
want in our children, we accept in
the President. We accept a President
who lies,
a President who has a
long history of
mistreating women, of
worse things, right,
and so suddenly, me being
Christian, I can defend the behavior of
something because I have, maybe,
that I defend his ideology and his
work plan, his governance plan, but
the values he represents, I can't, no, no, no,
can't understand that, and I don't know how you
see if from your perspective
This topic is very interesting because it's
more interesting now because Biden is
Catholic, and we have no doubt that
he's Catholic, but before getting to
Biden, in 2016
Trump had to build almost as if it were a
Christian character in a sense, with,
he decided at age 68, after being
in favor of legal abortion his whole
life, he decided at age 68,
he met the son of a friend who told
him that at one point, she thought
that maybe she would abort and decided not
to abort, and Trump met this son and he
liked him so much, and that's why he changed his position
and now is against abortion. Now,
for me, this is not a very believable story,
but it was a story that gave the
Christian voter at least
the possibility of saying, look, he changed
his view, eventually,
it took him 68 years, but eventually he got to
the appropriate position. For example
in an interview famously saying that
the bible is his favorite book, alongside
the book he wrote, so
the point is that the truth
has always been that for many of these
voters, particularly Evangelical
right wing Christian, it's not so much what
the candidate does, it's more what the candidate
says, and Trump is a perfect example
of that. Right, right. Do you think,
I'm asking you, do you think that the eight years
of Trump, of Obama -- sorry, I hope it's
not a prediction about eight years
of Trump. Have the eight years of Obama had
an effect, let's say,
a serious regressive effect, for example that
some American population felt,
could have felt so oppressed during those
eight years that suddenly they've exploded
and have gone public in a more open
way, I'm not sure why, for
example, the first black President of
the United States for eight years, who
didn't have major scandals, suddenly
it's like they felt so bothered by
the situation that suddenly they decided
to come out publicly, do you think it
might have been this way? How do you see it?
I think so, but, being careful
to be specific in that I want to say
yes, so let's see, to
start with, there is a group on the left
in the United States which argues that Obama caused
Trump from the standpoint of
being too centrist, Obama, in other words,
by not being a true leftist, disillusioned
the left about what a
Democratic President can be, to the extent that
many Democrats didn't vote at all in
2016, and that allowed Trump to win because
of course, in these three states by
some 77,000 votes.
I don't agree with this. No yes,
I do think that having a black President,
a President with a black father,
activated, didn't necessarily create, but
activated a movement that
already existed, and yes, that
could be a part of the expanation for
how Trump won in 2016, with 100
additional factors of course. In such
a tight election
many things can be what changes
who wins, for
example, Pennsylvania, but I do think
there was -- and the important thing is it wasn't
necessary that it be Trump, right? Other
Republican candidiates also
would have benefited from this group that
was activated, because there was a black
President for eight years
Right, right, David, as I mentioned
to you a moment ago, I worry that
suddenly, more than Trump, but
that
because yes, if many of Trump's
ideas can have a long term
effect beyond him, for example,
I think we've started to see
the effects, although the scientists
may not be 100% in agreement, and there isn't
a clear explanation, but the effects of
climate change. There are things that
had seen progress,
in environmental regulations to
protect certain things, for example now
we hear Trump saying that the
water that comes out of the shower isn't
enough, and you can't bathe,
that reminds me of an episode of Seinfeld
where they talk about the shower, right? And
so the impact of that worries me, that
the damage that can be done, which afterwards
to catch up in such things, for
example in the national parks,
in natural resources,
it worries me, will there be a Trump effect which
afterwards will do damage, possibly
irreversible? Or for example,
as we spoke about the
Postal Service, which suddenly
he's damaged so much, could it be privatized?
And there's no turning back? How do you see
that aspect?
Well, I agree, and that's why I think
that this election is so important, very
vert important, and I'd use the word
danger when we are considering what
could happen in the next four
years. Now there are certain things that
can change, in not too much
time, things that Trump did with executive
orders, for example, especially the
things that are sort of he directs a
certain department to not pay atteantion to
something, or that, that
can be changed in little time
from the standpoint of the environment,
there, yes, each day wasted is
a day that will evaporate and can't
be recovered, and doubles the work which will
be necessary when someone who is
at least at minimum, accepts the science
takes control and is in control
so for me, that's the most dangerous
part of what's going on
Intermediate to this is, for example the
topic of the healthcare system
Well look, we lost for years, the
system wasn't improve, for now Trump hasn't
worsened that much, he's worsened it a little, but
with some luck in two years if Biden wins and
especially if Democratsa win the
Senate, maybe in the next two years
there can be another improvement to
the healthcare system, so there's a spectrum
of things that can be turned around in short
time,
the lost causes, and the intermediate
Look, I remember the case of
Clinton, I remember that -- I don't remember the book
I read, they talked about how
Clinton was an avid reader,
he read a lot, he was a very informed
person, I remember that they even said
Clinton, in his case
he even read fiction
books, and later asked,
this scenario that this novel presents,
is it possible? But he was a person who read
a lot, and suddenly, when we find a --
you even mentioned science now -- and
suddenly the image came to mind
of how if you can put the light into the
veins, or something with injecting
disinfectant into the body, and what worries
me is also the damage to the community
where suddently the science, the facts, the
statistics are no longer important if, if
they contradict muy beliefs, right? And
there are, for example what one can be
sick and can believe what they want to,
that's a cough, or flu, whatever,
but if you go to the doctor, the doctor
diagnoses it, that's the reality, that's
what happened, right? You can say what you
want, but those are the facts. That's what worries
me, the damage to how
a community or a country changes its way
of thinking, its ways of accepting what
are facts, what is the truth, and when
now we have such a historic
and incredible crisis, without precedent, at least
in the last 100 years, right,
that science has to take an important
role to be able to manage it, we understand
the pressure of the economy and jobs, and
of that, but suddenly science isn't
that important because a
President doesn't pay attention to it, I don't know,
the impact on the nation worries me,
on the kids who are growing up,
who are being educated, that worries me
Yes, this is a cultural problem, it's a
problem with the education system, it's a
media problem, it's a very
complicated problem with many components and
in different parts of the country, it's more
versus less a problem. In other words,
there are parts of the country where the problem
can be
churches, particularly right wing churches
who say and teach that
they should not believe science. In other
parts of the country, it's more of an economic
problem, where the schools are
poorer and so it's not out of malice, but
an economic issue, where
the students aren't learning
how to think through certain types of problems, and
that type of thing, and also there's the
cultural problem, in other words, in 2012
it was more -- well, it's equally problematic
now but people were speaking more in these
terms in 2012 and 2016, about the
educational system as fundamentally
a left wing system which would
indoctrinate students, and that
cases a hostility, right? Against the
system, so depending on the moment,
depending on the part of the country, there
are three or four different problems that
come together there, which you mentioned, and I
don't know what the solution is. Right, right, no and
again, the issue with - you mention
that you don't know the solution, the issue is that
many times one doesn't know the solution, or
one does know, but that doesn't impeded us
from paying attention, and devoting mental time
and energy to try to see
things,
not to accept everything -- right, we have big
challengers and we have to confront them, we
can't say, nah, let them decide for
me. I believe that on this program, for
now on this podcast, we haven't spoke about
many political things, but here we have
entered into this topic
today because it worries me, the part about how
many people, as I mentioned,
suddenly don't...normal things, like what
is science, what are statistics, the
facts, things that are real suddently
aren't considered seriously, and I think it's
our responsibility as citizens
in Puerto Rico, and in any other country, to be
alert and informed, to know, and to make
decisions, we can't
cede these decisions to other people or
to someone who will tell us how to decide, I
think this is the part of us,
the free will of being able to analyze, being able to
choose, being able to evaluate, we have to
do it, an if you choose to vote for, for
some political leader because you believe in
their platform, well, well good,
but I believe that it's the responsibility
of each citizen to pass judgment and make
the analysis within -- right? -- within the
capacity that one has to judge that
I believe it's very important, as you
mention, it's common in an era that is
dangerous
I agree, and the only thing
I'd add is that there is a political
movement on the right which would say what
you said, and nothing else, from the standpoint of
look, it's the job of each individual
to be informed and to decide, period. Good, yes,
but also, we hae to ensure that
the educational system is working, and
working well, we have to ensure
that the media is functioning as it
should, and we don't want to stop
short at "each person should informed themselves," bye.
That's it. Right? And I think that's also
important. Yes, yes, no, I understand, I understand
your point. What I want to tell you is that
for example, some time ago,
I don't remember who was speaking, about how
often, when, I think
often,
we want to do things which will
facilitate the process of our lives
right, for example in the part about
labels, I think that when each child
grows up, they the concept of
"this is good," "this is bad," "this is --"
The labels can help to learn,
to develop, but there comes a moment
in our lives when the labels
become, that you are on the left,
the right, liberal, progressive,
and suddenly the labels become
a difficult way to explain things that
are more complicated, and so when you
that they, us, the Republican
Party against the Democratic
Party, so people say
well, I choose, I choose to be part of
this tripe, and they can tell me, right,
that they can tell me how to think, they can tell me how
to behave, right, and in that
sense of,
as a citizen, now to relinquish that
responsibility, right, that we have to
be responsible and not cede
our, our mental process to
someone who tells me how I should do
things, and I think that's my way of
seeing it
Of course, and it's also important
to understand that -- in other words, to be exposed
to that fact there's a more detailed
infrastructure, a deeper infrastucture to evaluate
what we see in the world, and how one can
think about problems and make decisions,
and that's the part that sometimes,
from my point of view the American
right prefers not to inform about, and not
to prepare people for, starting from when
they are kids, to be able to do
Right, right. David,
I really appreciate your willingness to
have this conversation because,
again, I found out about you through
the social networks, and
I love, I like your way of
not of just presenting ideas to present ideas,
but presenting ideas to favor a thinking
process, of look, evaluate.
Take decisions. Which is not, right, it's
very important at this time that
we understand, right, that we have to
inform ourselves, take decision, and not
cede our responsibility to
other people, and I really appreciate that
you've accepted this opportunity
to talk with me
Where can people find you,
they can find you on your website,
on your channels?
Of course the most central place and the
easiest place is my website,
davidpakman.com, and of course I have
a YouTube channel, they can find me
on Twitter, wheverer they want, I'm all
over the place, and I really appreciate the
invitation,
and hopefully we can do it again
Right, right, David something I want to
mention to people who watch
this show is that you
have, for people who are, let's say
digital entrepreneurs, who want to create
content, you have a Membership
system
where you generate revenue within your
own ecosystem, right, which has been,
there are people who depend on
Patreon,
YouTube ads, right, can you talk
to us a little bit about that part, share
some education for anyone who
can take ideas about how to do things
on social networks,
on YouTube, etc. Yes, sure, well so the
idea is that my primary show, which is
one hour per day, free to everyone,
and is available for everyone with some
ads in the show, we
put that on YouTube, there's a podcast, all of that,
and the idea from the start was that
some portion of our audience
probably, number on has a few
dollars per month with which
they can support us, and number two, are interested
in something extra in addition to
the daily show, so
we have this membership system an
case in point, those who sign up on
our website
can get a version of the show
without ads, and also an extra
program every day that we
do especially for them, and with that,
we estimate that under one percent
of the audience does this,
but eventually if the total audience is
large enough, that one percent or
a little less starts to add up
to important numbers to be able to support
a business, so that's our primary
revenue source for the business. Right, we
always talk about how one should find
different "income streams," right, in English,
to find methods of creating
revenue sources for your digital
business, that it not be solely, for
example, from affiliates, that it not be solely
from ads, right, that's the
advantage, I'm mentioning now,
that you mentioned, because I believe it's a
very, and example of a very
successful model from the content creation
side of social networks, and anybody
who wants to use your example
to follow a model
that has been successful for you.
Yes, and what you have to keep in mind
is that it can take, well for me, years,
years, for years they were few members, each
year few new members, but over time
keeping up the effort, over time
it started to be somethign more significant that
allowed us to hire
employees, and keep growing, and
improving what we were doing, but
it was with effort, and after many
years. Right, David, I'm super honored to
have had this conversation with you today
I'm hugely grateful that you accepted this
invitation, and once again I'm a follower
of yours on the social networks, keep creating
valuable, informative content
Thanks likewise, it was a pleasure
And without more to add, we'll meet
again on the next episode of
"Nos Cambiaron Los Muñequitos," until the
next one
[Música]